we're really interested in educating
leaders and leaders are change agents
the most phenomenal attribute of the
program is the people in it the
international differences the industry
differences we don't seek students that
are really seeking a typical experience
we seek people that are trying to set
themselves apart I wasn't looking to
change my career I was looking to turbo
boost in the Stanford MSX program is a
one-year master's degree at Stanford
Graduate School of Business designed
specifically for more experienced
leaders given my background I wanted to
be able to get access to the top faculty
in the world I wanted to be able to do
it in a sufficient amount of time as
possible so I could get back to my
career
this is a center of innovation and
Stanford is the engine that feeds
Silicon Valley being in Silicon Valley
is inspirational there's that Hope
energy around the entrepreneurial spirit
energy around being very creative
but I come into class I see an ocean of
very distinguished people who already
achieved a lot I love my MSX khop born
in Cairo raised in Texas citizen of
Sweden moved here from Dubai I'm from
Delhi from Portland Oregon from France
from China in the airline business
private equity business touristic
industry market strategy market planning
I've been in Singapore Army for the last
18 years of my life there's an
incredibly broad spectrum of skills and
expertise we studied together in study
groups everyone adds a bit of magic to
the outcome when you immerse yourself in
the Stanford GSB environment you can't
fail to be bowled over by the quality of
the professor's the policy of the people
many of our students want to go all the
way to become CEO they're ambitious
they're a little bit impatient and they
feel that the experience here will speed
up their advancement I may have come
here as a core technologist but I feel
like I actually left here with the
confidence and the credibility to be a
general manager as managers the MSX
student they need to be designers of the
organization a year spent in MSX program
helped me in all the ways I had imagined
it would and frankly no several that I
hadn't anticipated my identity still has
a designer today but now I have a
broader palette firmer foundation it
takes some guts to take a year off from
a career people here are really thinking
about how can I make a seismic change
change me from my China domestically
focused a businessman into a
international businessman it's a great
environment to innovate an experiment
it's a great experience for both the
professional part and the family life
then we've met our neighbors our kids
started hanging out the day we moved
here my son ran through the house before
we even unpacked the car he was out the
back door in the central play area these
are the kinds of connections that will
take us to our next life I feel like I
came here as something and I left is
something different it's been an amazing
journey since then